what do you like to do and what are your
goals what are your needs and and based
on that you decide what's going to work
for you if you like what you do you're
going to end up spending time doing it
and all the time that you spend with the
language is good so if someone says it
you know comes up with a very structured
for example mnemonic system and you
associate words with colors or flowers
or images or someone says you should
write very early because it's good for
you it is good to write but if you don't
want to write you'll end up not doing it
if you like listening to songs or we had
keith in japan who liked watching movies
even when he didn't understand them
if he spends a lot of time doing that
that's good for him um i've had many
people tell me that they they will uh
have say spanish on in the background at
work there's many places in the united
states where there's
spanish radio so at work they'll have
spanish on the background and that they
claim that that helps them learn the
language and i am sure it does it's not
something that i would do
so
simply because i would find it a bit
distracting but i am sure it's good for
you i'm sure it's good for you uh so all
i'm saying is that there are many many
different ways to learn the most
important thing is that you like what
you're doing